hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to cannibal din the theme of
some of my favorite games from the
Newgrounds era of gaming this one came
along and kind of spawned a new genre of
gaming if you don't know about it you
never played it before I highly
recommend checking out it's got a dick
t'v simplistic gameplay which is kind of
the secret ingredient of many app games
things on the iPhone or Android or
whatever you play it on but either way
about this game is it came out no 9 and
I don't know if it's the first in its
genre but it is con at the beginning of
the endless runner fiasco that happened
that I called a fiasco because I think
that it's over played at this point if
you've ever played like Temple Run or
anything like that then you know about
endless runners because Scott Gaiman I'm
much better at this game than it's gonna
seem and I challenge you guys to be my
score when you play for yourself because
it is very very fun and simplistic and
addicting and that's kind of what game
developers have tried to tap into and
especially with the App Store and
whatnot and trying to get games out like
that they end up making a lot of money
and there's a few reasons why they make
a lot of money and they're very
addicting and people love to play it
it's one simplest simplistic and easy to
get into it's kind of got the flappy
bird style
anyone can play it but it's very hard to
master to type a deal it's also got a
different aspect to it that I was trying
to come up with a way to say it
before I started recording but I had
trouble when I was doing research about
this game I know that the developers
made this game at about five days for a
particular game jam they styled it after
like the rooftop sequence from Casino
Royale and then Mad Men and a whole
bunch of other things like that but well
okay well I died there but what it came
from what came out of it rather after it
was made was this whole attitude about
games that could be simple and easy to
get into that weren't entirely complex
now whether it's easy to develop or not
because this one was made in five days
but I'm willing if I wasn't looking I
was looking at the camera I apologize
but I'm willing to bet that something
like Temple Run takes months and months
and years to develop because the
developers fine-tuning it to try to tap
into that perfect market so that
everyone's gonna play and everyone's
gonna share it and everyone's gonna love
it forever and ever and we are willing
to shell out a lot of their money but
when I
get a game like this and I try to see
why it's a fun game in particular which
I think a lot of developers miss out on
when it comes to a fun game but the
reason why this one is a fun game to me
and got really popular very quickly and
sticks in the mind of a lot of people
when they think of an endless runner is
because this one in forgot I can get
this I'm gonna games I swear but the
reason why this one is good in
particular is because there's a
fundamental concept there it's a
single-player game that's true like only
one person can play this at a time but
it spawns all god I put I press the
button I pit it it's a single-player
game that spawns a multiplayer
experience and what I mean by that is
that one person plays this game but this
game is fun and it's hard it's simple
fun the concept was new at the time and
it was very addicting to play because
you wanted to beat your score all the
time and that's like the old style of
gaming it was very hard
you died instantly and you wanted to
beat your score but this one in
particular is good because it's so easy
for people to get into I literally only
press one button and the only
Constitution god and made that jump the
only Constitution is skill is your
reaction time and how quickly you can do
certain things and how quickly you can
accomplish obstacles so it's a
single-player game but it spawns a
multiplayer experience in that you go
out and you share this game with others
not so much to share it because it's fun
but to share it because it's fun and you
bet you can beat your friend at it like
that's really what it all comes down to
is because there's a challenge to it and
when there's a challenge to a game
there's this incentive for competition
ah and I dyed it as an incentive for
competition in that people want to see
other people perform worse than you did
and it's weird because like games that
tap into the competitive aspect of
certain things like nowadays not so much
as they did in the past but the games
that originally did and wanted people to
incentivize being better than their
peers at a surprise what's on the jump
it's an even register okay whatever that
was told bull right there I dare you
guys I sincerely dare you guys and also
if you do know what games came before
this that were endless runner genre type
games please let me know in the comments
below I know that I'm not entirely right
about a lot of things so I want to be
very careful about what I say and all
this is just my opinion if you have your
own opinion please let me know in the
comments below but like like what I was
saying about the the competitive aspect
of the game period is that there's so
much also mysteriousness to the game god
I wish I could say more and concentrate
at the same time cuz there's a lot going
on here another reason why it is this
could be bare-bones black and white no
the guy isn't obviously in a suit the
guy isn't anything there's no background
or anything like that and the game would
be fun but the addition of the fact that
there are ships flying by there's like
missiles or turbines crashing into the
ceilings there's buildings that are
falling down you can see in the
background there's machines like
crawling around gigantic machines based
on the size of the landscape like right
there you can see like two machines in
the background like what is all that why
is all that and the music is phenomenal
like the music is addicting it fits with
the theme of the game does Rumble this
sounds as birds flying up everywhere
it's such a simple game and yet there's
so much going on to it that kind of adds
to it like the theme of Temple Run is
that yeah you're just running away but
if you weren't running away from those
monsters it would be less interest in it
I think God I can get this I swear god
I'm trying to concentrate on my thoughts
and I don't want to get all over the
place like I wasn't spewer I was trying
to say a lot of things when I was
playing spewer but III God press the
button okay hey give me a second here
I'm pressing Lee I bet the C the C
buttons broken controllers broke the
keyboards broken it's not my fault
anyway so there's a lot going on in a
very simple package there's a lot
appealing to the eyes because it's
fast-paced but also each time you play
you register a bit more of the
background at a time and each time you
play you like you want to try to solve
the mystery but this is a game and there
are many games like this that doesn't
ever explain itself and it doesn't need
- it doesn't need to explain itself
because all of the clues are in the
environment and I've said that before
about games when I was playing them
before like I loved a game that tells
the story as the games going and you
don't need to know anything about it
like there was a I know when this first
came out there was a whole bunch of like
stories about why the world was coming
to an end apparently and why this guy
was running so fast on a rooftop to get
away from something or god damned if I
could stop hitting things it'd be
fantastic but why this guy was doing all
this stuff in the first place which is
part of the mystery of it and part of
what got people talking about in part of
people why people were sharing it and
the developer itself said that you know
he came up with a name because his kid
are those is there was a kid that said
can catapult weird Dan that God that is
hard it does get very hard and I don't
know what the maximum high score in the
world is I would love to know but it's
like that's all it was he came up with
themes inspired by Casino Royale and Mad
Men I don't know if I said that before
but and then he came up with the name
simply because his kids said catapult
here and cannonball I believe I was
reading a small article about this
because I wanted to know if this really
was the first endless runner game and
it's hard to say because I don't really
know I didn't research all that long but
if you guys do know please let me know
in the comments below yes finally god
that's like the hardest thing to get is
it you gotta hit it in just the right
angle so that you don't smack into a
wall before you go down but I mean just
I'm gonna concentrate before I end this
because I think I said everything that I
wanted to say and I want to show them
not all that bad at these guys gods the
cuz it's GOG good okay one more
time I'm going to get it god so
aggravating but I want to beat it that's
why it's games good that's why some
endless runners are actually good
because they do encourage that type of
thing basically if you didn't know if
you haven't played it for yourself and
you're just watching to play this one
you jump higher based on how hard you
hold the button that's literally the
only aspect of skill in this entire game
that's the only thing that you can
actually control because it goes on
itself I'm not even pushing myself
forward I can't slow myself down I can't
ah all right I just got to remember I
don't need to hold down that as long as
possible
and I'm gonna get a high score here I
want to get over 3,000 cuz I know with
my head score at the end of it was like
6,000 back when I played a long time ago
it was really high I was very proud of
it
alright a very big number to my name and
all my friends were horribly
embarrassing how much worse they were
than me at this game and I'm gonna get
good and also I think after this um
Robot Unicorn Attack came after it I
think that was made by the guys if I
don't swim haha I'd also in games and
then they came up with the concept of
that and kind of evolved on the concept
instead of just jumping you also had a
dash attack and then like game
developers after that kept adding to the
formula and I feel like in some way
that's good when you add to a formula
but also it's bad because it detracts
from the original experience of why this
game was so simple and fun not this a
that Robot Unicorn Attack is a bad game
I actually really liked that game it's
really fun and it evolved in the right
way but as with a lot of these games if
they evolve in the wrong way they can
actually be worse than the original
experience Scott dangus dang it this is
very very hard because I'm looking I'm
looking at where my character is and the
problem with this game I need to look
ahead at where my character is going to
be and just trust that I'm gonna be
there at the right time
and also a little pro tip markiplier pro
tip you you need to jump before you get
to the end of a complex so that you
don't you have time in the middle of the
air to predict what you're going to run
into because right there that's
important okay hit that that's not bad
I'm still going it's eventually if you
if you even hit an object and lose
momentum a little bit that's going to be
horribly detrimental to your long-term
play yep but I just need to be able to
predict what I'm gonna run in do I need
to see the whole picture at all one time
oh my god go to bed now I'm gonna bake
it oh my god I'm gonna make it okay
okay goodbye I didn't do it I didn't do
it god I was right there
Frick a frack well anyway that's all I'm
gonna embarrass myself with with this
game but if you haven't played it before
definitely check it out in the
description below there's a lot of other
games that spawned out of it so if you
got another one that kind of evolves in
the right way like I was saying please
let me know in the comments below I love
this game it's one of my favorite games
just because of how simple it is and how
easy to get into do back when it first
came out whenever I was working on
something else it was even easy to just
hop into the game and that's what a lot
of people do with their phones out they
just hop into a game just for a little
bit to try to beat a little more that's
part of the reason why flappy bird was
so popular - because it was obscenely
hard
what's so simple like everyone could get
into it and everyone wanted to see how
much better they were than their friends
so like I'm no game developer I'm no
game developer all I am is an enjoyer of
game so all my opinions are just that
they're just my opinions but I'd like to
think that I know my way around games
sometimes so let me know what you think
in the comments below if I'm a total
Pratt and just an idiot spouting
nonsense and let me know that also
though either way thank you all so much
for watching check out the other awesome
games that I played down in the
description below or in the annotations
over there and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye adventure book
I love it
I was spitting everywhere
oh that was